il y a des profs justement qui t'ont
marqué particulièrement que ce soit dans
les sciences au lycée ou autre ouais il
y en a eu alors j'ai beaucoup de c'est
fou mais j'ai pas mal de souvenirs de de
plein de
profs il y en a eu plein j'ai mon prof
de math de lycée qui s'appelle monsieur
Capel qui qui est vraiment un des
premiers qui qui m'a fait comprendre un
peu la rigueur scientifique tu sais que
les maths c'était pas juste on rigole
avec
c'était B trs ça va bonjour Thomason
c'est pas allez bien d'accord que
c'était pas triché on c'était pas triché
on l'a pas on l'a pas moi je savais il
était pas de passageci moi je sa il
était comment Thomas Pesquet en ah
Thomas c'était quelqu'un de discret
d'une part et extrêmement agréable comme
élève il se mettait pas en avant je
pense qu'il était bien apprécié de tous
ses camarades il me semble honnêtement
je trouvais aussi que à l'écrit il était
extrêmement clair si bien que quand tu
faisais une faute on la voyait
clairement